[Music]
right now Democrats are continuing to
fuel more impeachment hysteria we got
him again again except that's blowing up
in their face and it's not taking three
years to get to the truth and they of
course refuse to always let facts get in
the way the latest witch hunt and it's
putting the pressure squarely on Nancy
Pelosi here with reaction Fox News
contributor former Republican
congressman guy is a prosecutor never
lost a single case trey Gowdy
congressman tell me walk me through this
if you were prosecuting this case
against Joe Biden how hard would it be I
don't know I mean I you know the the
best to a prosecutor has is the ability
to cross-examine witnesses and no
offense to reporters but I couldn't use
anonymous sources in a courtroom and
every witness I called was
cross-examined so the reporters do
whatever it is they do I need to eyeball
the witness and judge credibility I
think here's what my fellow citizens
believe if you're going to investigate
one fact pattern you need to investigate
a nearly identical fact pattern what
they don't like is the duplicity always
looking at Republicans but having a
tendency to ignore look you just played
the clip the president itíd state said
I'll have more flexibility if I win a
second term I never heard a reporter ask
what he meant by that
never heard four calls for transcripts
before or after that conversation so the
duplicity is what drove me out of
politics and and look no offense to your
previous guest their reporters I'm not I
need to cross-examine people well the
thing I would like to understand is when
you have the vice president united
states saying you got six hours okay you
either you either fire that prosecutor
or I'm not giving you your billion
dollars there are billion dollar savings
now why would a vice president the
United States of America congressman
Gowdy why would a vice president ever
want a Ukraine prosecutor fired why
because John sighs attacking accuser
they got fired and that prosecutor said
he was about he knew that his son was
under investigation by that prosecutor
New York Times tipped them off to that
but the Sean Hannity I know would want a
question and examine Joe Biden and asked
him what he meant by gonna fire him but
you'd also want to examine the
prosecutor from the Ukraine who says I
was about to interview hunter Biden I
mean the curse of being a lawyer is you
really don't believe anybody until
you've examined them and cross-examined
them and look for corroboration I just
think the same fact pattern all to be
investigated with the same vigor and the
Adam Schiff that I used to work with
well but you know what it will happen
when your viewers and others demand that
it happened the Adam Schiff who spent
eight years covering for Barack Obama
and did everything in his power to
protect Hillary Clinton all of a sudden
now is a fan of transparency
I hope my fellow citizen can see through
the olicity of someone like Adam Schiff
Thank You congressman and the only one
on tape that was colluding with the
Russians who at least he thought they
were what's the nature of the compromise
naked pics at a Donald Trump megapix it
but of course Thank You congressman